l'ennemi que l'on a c'est un ennemi qui
met les petites fiches ou burqa qui leur
a interdit à l'école et qui jette les
homosexuels ou des toits c'est sous la
halle et demi qu'on a en face un enfin
vous faut bien le réaliser donc ces gens
là qui soit sous les verrous ou six
pieds sous terre ça nous va très bien
[Musique]
a commencé vers 6 heures du matin on
sera préparée depuis 5 heures
on est en extérieur qu'il pleuve qu'il
vente qu'il neige est là donc on va
préparer la première épreuve donc ce
sera pour soi une épreuve de course à
pied soit un parcours sur les
l'instruction ont déjà leur as ils
devront quelques minutes ensuite tout de
suite après ça on va repartir pour une
épreuve que les instruments de données
par exemple ils vont nous amener en bord
de mer et on va avoir 15 km à faire sur
une plage avec tout notre barda notre
armes et caetera le corps souffre
beaucoup
pendant le stage commando c'est pour ça
qu'on me dit qu'il faut avoir un mental
c'est le seul endroit au monde où on
vous dira vous avez mal et bien tant pis
c'est à vous de choisir
soit vous continuez malgré la douleur
soit vous arrêtez
mon plus grand d'achèvement
professionnels ça a été de décrocher mon
béret vert
on est en mission au moins une fois par
an
on est en
entraînement bonne partie du temps on a
très peu de temps pour voir sa famille
et ses proches
mais généralement c'est du coup de
sifflet ou deux jours avant on est
prévenu et paf ça part très vite donc la
mission ont elles mêmes ces démissions
en fonction de l'environnement où on est
qu'ils peuvent être mené en bateau qui
peuvent être menées en zodiac en grosses
embarcations ou en hélicoptère ou en vie
question que j'ai beaucoup aimé je suis
l'occasion de faire au sein de parcours
spécial c'est une mission devait
capturer un djihadiste c'était dans une
ville au sein d'une ville avec une
population qui était pas forcément
acquis à notre cause
donc c'était très délicat on rentre dans
cette ville en véhicule
on attend la nuit noire et on se déploie
autour du bâtiment où logent notre
dialogue et notre chef djihadiste est là
c'est assez surprenant mais les gars qui
étaient dans mon groupe c'était des
dégâts et ses dégâts qui sont sur
entraînés armés jusqu'aux dents
et pourtant là ils ont fait une
opération tout en finesse on est rentré
dans la maison on a enjambé des gens qui
dormaient pour capturer notre homme de
manière isolée
on a confirmé que c'était lui on l'a mis
sous protection et on en à partir de là
messieurs de la maison comme on est venu
sans un coup de feu sans un bruit et la
famille dormaient encore
[Musique]
c'est toujours une très grande tristesse
un brillant tristesse mais c'est le jeu
c'est le jeu et moi je crois dans le dos
quand ils meurent dans des champs de
bataille qui est une mort glorieuse mais
moi je crois dans le sacrifice féconder
ernst young heures je crois que le la
mort de ces jours là n'est jamais vaine
[Musique]
la première fois où on est sous le feu
on va et on se dit c'est ça y est c'est
maintenant on se dit c'est là où ça se
passe vraiment on a été très entraînés
on est très bien préparé pour ces
situations là mais ça reste une surprise
quand vous avez les balles qui sifflent
le sable qui soulève vous voyez l'éclat
des fusils qui claquent
du coup c'est assez impressionnant mais
il faut prendre le dessus et puis il
faut se battre à le tuer le gars avant
qu'ils nous tuent nous c'est un geste
qui est qu'on nous apprend et qu'on fait
qui devient presque un geste technique
un sens vous sans pour autant que ça
devienne un geste inhumain cirque on va
pas tuer par plaisir on veut pas ça par
plaisir
ce qu'on aime c'est gagner des batailles
les limites que l'on a c'est un ennemi
qui met les petites filles burqa qui
leur interdit l'école et qui jette les
homosexuels de vue des toits
c'est sous la halle et mais qu'on a en
face enfin vous faut bien le réaliser
donc ces gens là qui soit sous les
verrous ou six pieds sous terre ça nous
va très bien
il utilise le mot de croiser en fait on
est les représentants d'un idéal
occidental c'est une guerre de
civilisation qu'il mène là bas et ça
c'est très important à comprendre pour
pouvoir comprendre l'entraînement eux
s'ils gagnent dans mille ans et seront
ils se rencontrent en se contentant qui
sont patients et d'attendre
ils attendent ils attendent un
changement gouvernement et s'attendre à
un changement de président il attend un
changement de deux chefs d'état major
des armées
[Musique]
j'ai j'avais un copain au téléphone la
qui venait de rentrer de mission au
moyen orient et m'a dit on en éliminant
il y en a dix qui sortent je pense aussi
que ça passe par restructurer notre
utilisation déjà pour qu'on ait quelque
chose à offrir à ces jeunes à ces jeunes
du sahel du levant qui n'ont rien
aujourd'hui qui n'ont que la pauvreté et
à qui on propose un portable une
kalachnikov et une brutalité d'armes on
leur propose un mondial qui est puissant
qui forts et beaux et grands cinq
hameaux alentours et qu'elle a qu'elle
mérite d'exister
disons que ça nous on leur offre croit
comme idéal dans l'offre ou quoi l'offre
starbucks netflix et et ils défilent de
la hollywoodien ça nourrit pas pense
qu'on doit faire plus et ceux plus je
vais essayer de l'accomplir dans le
civil par différentes actions
[Musique]